do you know what I hate about the  Americans everything I need you smile  especially Cowboys  let me Anakin yeah New York I oak up  yeah it's gonna be long as you know as a  cop you don't look like a lawyer  jerk dad this is what you've been doing  double oh seven Oh Plainfield New Jersey  relax you're safe now  save my ass this guy's bad news  terrorism weapons-grade uranium nukes  always gotta stop it at a point  knock knock  whoa but it's just a pirate gun it's old  school like you right right I guess  you've done this before not encouraging  me and my boy here I got a whooping are  you really really  open  you go looking for trouble or does it  always fight you listed ask myself the  same question